FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm here to
introduce Lori Kenschaft.
Lori describes herself as
an intellectual omnivore.
Her undergrad degrees
from Swarthmore
are in biology and religion.
She got her master's
from Harvard Divinity
School in theological studies,
and her Ph.D. from Boston
University was in
American Studies.
I describe Lori as a
personal friend, as well as
an all-around
fascinating person.
She hosts lectures
and discussions
on all sorts of
topics, including
but not limited to politics,
economics, charitable giving,
religion, and mass
incarceration, the last two
being related to her positions
as clerk of the First Parish
Unitarian Universalists
of Arlington,
and coordinator of their mass
incarceration working group.
Her diverse background gives
her an interesting and informed
perspective in all
of these topics.
Today, she's here to talk
a bit about her third book,
"Gender Inequality in
Our Changing World."
And I'll hand you off to Lori.
LORI KENSCHAFT:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
I want to thank all
of you for being here,
particularly Jonathan
for inviting me,
and Tim for handling the
mechanics of making the thing
work.
So just a brief background,
"Gender Inequality
in Our Changing World" is a
brand new textbook, sociology.
I'm an historian, more
or less-- as we said,
intellectual omnivore.
But I teamed up with a couple
sociologists to write this.
And the reason we did this is
because the sociology of gender
textbooks that are
out there now tend
to have been written in
the 1990s, when there
was this really sort of
triumphalist sort of idea
that the United
States is the norm,
everybody's headed our
way, Washington consensus.
And they've had updated
editions since then,
but the fundamental
conceptualization
reflects that era.
And it seemed to us that
we live in a much more
diverse and complicated
world than we did--
or than people thought
they did-- in the 1990s.
And so we teamed
up together to try
to focus on what's
going on with gender
inequality in the
contemporary United States,
but really put it in a richly
international, global context,
and in an historical context.
So we were focusing on
the theme of change.
How do things change,
what is changing,
what's changing more
quickly, what's changing
more slowly, all of this.
It's one of those huge
topics that, if I'd
realized what I
was getting into,
I probably would've said no.
But in retrospect,
I'm glad I said yes.
And I'm very grateful that
you are all here today.
What I'm planning to do
is what I call a flyover.
It's a 450-page book,
or something like that,
and I'm going to try to
talk about it in 30 minutes.
So there's no way I can
touch on everything in there,
but I'm just giving you a
flyover perspective of what's
in the book, and
some of the things
that I think people
might find interesting.
I'm going to ask that, while I'm
going this quick speed through,
people not comment or
question during the slides,
because several of these
I included in the book
because they're so interesting
that, if I were in a classroom,
I could use them to do 20 or
30 minutes of conversation
right there in the classroom.
And that's not the
goal for today.
So please do not be
triggered by the slides
into conversation until
the end, and then there
will be time for Q&A.
I'm going to try to keep
this very hard to 30 minutes.
Make sense?
So the first question is,
where is gender inequality?
And there are three
different maps
that I'm going to show you
that are looking at gender
inequality on a global scale.
This one is the United Nations
has a Gender Inequality Index.
And any metric you
use, any index you use,
has its problems.
Like this one makes
Saudi Arabia look
sort of the same as
the United States,
and that's because lots and
lots of women in Saudi Arabia
go to a university and get high
education because they're not
allowed to do anything else.
Their brothers are allowed
to go work, go play sports,
be with friends, go
socialize, whatever,
and all the young women
can do is go to university,
so they go to university.
And that makes the
society look like it
has very good equality for
women, if you measure it just
by education.
So clearly, we have some
problems with this index.
But there are some patterns
here that are real.
It is true that, by
many different metrics,
the United States has
more gender inequality
than most wealthy democracies.
And the two places that
are changing most quickly
are China over the last
60 years and Latin America
over the last 20 years.
And Latin America is
changing very quickly
also in terms of
economic inequality.
It's the only
region of the world
in which economic inequality
has decreased over the last 20
years rather than increased.
So there's interesting
things going
on in both of those countries.
And in China, that's
very intentional.
The communist government,
when it came in,
said, women hold
up half the sky.
They said that girls had
to get primary education,
that employment had
to open up to women.
And it takes a while for these
things to percolate through,
but China is
changing very quickly
as a result partly of
intentional policies.
But that's not all
that's going on.
So the next metric that
I would like to offer
is this is gender gaps
in life expectancies.
And one of the key
distinctions here
that sociologists of gender,
gender studies people, use
is between sex and gender.
Sex is what we're born with.
Whatever it is, however
complicated it is,
it's what we're
born with related
to reproductive
anatomy, and everything
that goes along with that.
Gender is what cultures
make of that, how
cultures put meaning on that.
So, sex, males are more
likely to die at every age.
That includes prenatally.
So this is when nobody
knows, until recently,
what sex they are.
So that has to do with sex.
Gender affects how that
happens, how quickly it happens,
the balance between them.
There are societies in
which it's not true.
which women die younger.
That's high level of
gender inequality.
There are societies
in which women
live much longer than
men, and that is also--
excessively longer than men.
And that is also a form
of gender inequality.
So the countries that
are marked in red
are the countries
where the gender
gap is too long, that men are
being disadvantaged by gender.
And that has a lot
to do with violence,
has a lot to do with
alcohol, has a lot
to do with
risk-taking behaviors.
And then the blue countries are
where women are likely dying
of gender, although
in a few cases,
I think the gap is small because
medical care is really good.
It's not like Iceland up there
is a particularly bad country
for women.
But that gives you
another perspective
on the patterns here
of gender inequality.
Here's another
perspective on this.
Again, if we have a natural
sex ratio-- and all of this
is a little difficult
to tell what's natural,
because there's no culture
that doesn't have culture.
So we're sort of guessing
where the natural state is.
But the natural state seems
to be that about 1.05 boys are
born for every girl.
Of course, we really should say
105 boys for every 100 girls,
but.
And there are a
variety of countries
where that's not true.
So India, China, some
other smaller countries,
have many more boys per girl
than would be average born,
would be natural born.
And that's because of
sex-selective abortion.
And notice that India and China
together contain about 1/3
of the world's population.
So when you have those
countries selecting strongly
for male births, that means
we have a real disproportion
in the population.
The red countries
are where there's too
few girls-- boys born.
And the reasons for that are
not completely understood,
but I believe that
at least-- I'm
sure that at least
part of the answer
is that, when a woman is
stressed during pregnancy,
male fetuses are more likely
to miscarry, back to males
are more likely to
die at every age.
Males are more fragile.
So those countries are
countries, I believe,
in which women are so often
so stressed during pregnancy
that their sons in utero
are more likely to die.
So gender inequality
affecting both the woman
and the next generation.
So those are three ways
of thinking about what's
the big patterns here.
There are four key
causes a of inequality
that we outline in the book, and
this is where the book starts.
Economics.
Nearly all societies use gender
to allocate who does what work,
and to give-- and
nearly all societies
give men preferential access and
control to economic resources.
The degree of that varies a lot,
how that works varies a lot,
but that seems to be
very, very common.
Families.
Nearly all societies assign the
majority of unpaid family care
work to women.
Child care, elder care,
cooking and cleaning,
and just keeping
everybody alive.
It seems to be women's
ultimate responsibility
to keep their families alive.
Control of sexuality.
Patrilineal societies
are societies
where family membership
and inheritance
are traced through
the man's line,
through the father's line.
And the simple frame of
that is you get the name
of your father's family.
But in patrilineal
societies, there
are many societies
where only sons inherit
from their fathers,
or only fathers
can bequeath to their
sons and daughters.
But it's all
through the fathers.
Matrilineal societies,
you trace inheritance
through your mother's line.
Now, this results in very
different types of societies,
because obviously we
all know-- a given baby,
we're pretty sure
who the mom is.
We're not necessarily
sure who the father is.
And so societies that are
patrilineal and consider
patrilineal tracing
to be really important
have to control
women's sexuality,
their reproductive capacity.
And that means basically
all of their behavior,
so that there can't be any
doubts about which baby
is assigned to which man.
And how stringently
that's done varies a lot,
but there's a
fundamental difference
between patrilineal and
matrilineal societies.
The vast majority of people have
lived in patrilineal society.
And then, violence.
Traditional societies
worldwide expect the male head
of household, the
men who are in charge
of the family and,
therefore, the society,
to maintain discipline
within the families.
And usually violence is
an acceptable method.
And in addition, nearly
everywhere the threat
of sexual violence
constrains women's lives
in a variety of different ways.
There's a lot we
could say about that.
So starting with
economics, the type
of economic system
that a society has
affects the degree of
gender inequality in it.
And it's not a
tight correlation,
but sociology is always
about loose correlations.
There's always going to
be exceptions to the rule.
Hunting-gathering
economies, you share food.
You can't really own much
in the way of anything else,
because you have to be
able to carry it with you.
There isn't much economic
inequality to be had.
Horticultural economies, which
use hoes and other hand tools
but don't have big plows
or domestic animals--
big domestic animals-- tend
to have separate cultures
for women and men.
They use gender to assign
the work roles very strongly,
but there tends to be a sort of
balance of power between them.
Agricultural and pastoral
or herding economies
tend to be the most unequal.
They tend to have what's
called family economies, where
the whole family-- whatever
that definition is--
works together to
keep everybody alive,
to create all the things
that are necessary.
And the men of the family are
given control of the resources
that are necessary, ownership
of the land or the animals
or whatever their
core resource is,
and also the right, and
therefore the responsibility,
to control the
family labor force.
i.e., the women and children.
So that's the most
unequal type of society.
In industrial
economies, you begin
to open up room for individuals
to earn their own incomes,
including for women to
earn their own incomes.
And that makes it
possible for women
to have a degree of independence
that is impossible in a family
economy.
This affects obviously
the women who
are earning their own
incomes, but it also affects
women who aren't,
because they have
that possibility available
culturally, economically.
And so industrialized
societies tend
to increase gender
equality, increase the focus
on the individual as the
unit of decision-making.
Knowledge-based economies
like the one we're in,
especially here in this
building, value intelligence,
expertise, creativity,
social and relationship
and emotional skills,
and the ability
to sit still and
focus and concentrate.
These are all skills
that women tend
to have at least as much as men.
And so in knowledge-based
economies,
there tends to be
increased gender equality.
Although, as we have seen,
nowhere has become gender
equal.
In the United States,
now if you look
at young adults aged 25
to 29, 37% of the women
and 30% of the men have
a bachelor's degree.
So we're really
seeing a shift there.
But if you control
for education,
then men earn more than women
in every demographic group,
including young singles,
unmarried, don't have kids.
The sort of most
free individuals,
still men earn more than
women if you correlate,
correct for education.
Two key factors are important
for increasing gender equality
within families.
Again, if we look worldwide.
One of them is women having
access to reproductive health
care-- contraception,
abortion, maternity care--
and not having genital cutting,
particularly infibulation.
Women's lives--
you know, it just
affects so many things
in a woman's life
if she can control when
she's going to have children,
and if she has a really good
chance of surviving childbirth,
which, in some societies,
each time a woman gives birth,
she risks dying and her children
risk ending being motherless.
The other key thing is if
men bond with their children
and become engaged
with their infants,
they are much more
likely to continue
to care for their children
throughout those children's
lives.
So this is where we
see this sex and gender
thing, that it really
makes a difference when
what's seen sociologically
is that when men take
paternity leave, some amount
of time when their infants are
small that's long enough
to bond with that child,
that affects how they
behave as fathers
for the rest of their lives.
So that requires paid
paternity leave, or generally
paid paternity leave to
be available to have this
be really common, and policies
that overcome social pressures.
So in most countries,
maybe all countries,
there's some degree
of stigma against men
who prioritize child care.
And the countries that have been
most successful in getting men
to do this are the ones that
create maternity leave first,
and then what's called
parental leave, which
can be taken by other
parent, but they
require men to take some amount
of paternity leave dedicated
for men first.
And then either parent can
take the parental leave.
And those societies are
seeing-- the stats--
I'm sure there's
a limit to this,
but for each month
of paternity leave
a man takes, his-- the
mother of his children,
not always his wife--
has a 7% increase
in earnings in the future.
So this is really significant.
One note here is
that women tend to,
in the United States and
other advanced countries--
economically advanced
countries-- still are having
huge what's called
motherhood penalties,
that when a woman
is a mother, she
earns less and is less likely
to get hired or promoted really
for the rest of her life, even
if you control for experience.
It's not just oh, she took
some time out of the workforce,
she's a little behind
in accumulating
education and experience.
Even if you control
for that, women still
earn less if they are mothers.
Men, on the other hand, earn
more if they are fathers.
And it's not just because
they tend to work more,
which the men did
when they have kids.
They say, OK, I really
need to focus on this.
Even if you control
for that, men
tend to earn more
if they are fathers,
get this fatherhood bonus,
as long as they do not--
there are two criteria.
One, if a man spends
significant time taking
care of his own
children, then he
doesn't get the
fatherhood bonus.
Like if he takes that paternity
leave, probably won't get it.
And if he has brown skin.
You have to be white to
get the daddy bonus, which
is related to, but not the same
as, African American men are
much more likely than
white American men
to be equal or close to
equal partners around taking
care of small children.
So there's a lot of different
factors going on here.
OK.
This is one of my
favorite charts.
This is about
control of sexuality,
but using it from a more
statistical point of view.
If you look at the percent
of people in a society saying
that their society should
accept homosexuality,
there's a strong correlation
with the per capita GDP.
This is $70,000
there, $0 down there.
And as you can see, there's
a pretty strong correlation.
But there's also a
lot of diversity.
And that diversity, I
would argue, is cultural.
So there are countries,
or whole regions,
that are much more likely
to accept homosexuality
than others than
predicted by their GDP.
So these sort of
purple dots up there,
those are European countries.
And they tend to be
relatively embracing.
These green dots here are
Latin American countries,
which are poor, but also
more embracing for their GDP.
These red countries down
here sub-Saharan Africa.
Don't be born there
if you're gay.
And then these are Muslim
majority countries,
those orange dots.
This is the United States,
which is pretty tolerant but not
nearly as much as
you would think based
on its GDP, statistically.
And the reason this
is so important,
it's not just because
of what it means
for gay folk in these
societies but also
because what tolerance
of homosexuality means
is a belief that sexuality
belongs to the individual.
That in this traditional,
family-based patrilineal
systems, sexuality
belongs to the family.
It is part of
reproducing the family,
it is part of creating
that labor force.
Women's bodies are
very tightly controlled
so that the family has its
official integrity, often
described as
purity, kept intact.
The more a society
sees sexuality
as an individual
thing, something
about individual
choice, something
about individual preference
and pleasure and relationship,
but a matter of individual
choice, the more people go hey,
it's a matter of
individual choice.
You can choose who
you're going to be with.
So this is a metric for
how much a society has
moved from seeing
sexuality as a property
of the family to
seeing sexuality
as a property of the individual.
So it's a very important
graph from that point of view.
And again, this is what I mean
by Latin American countries
are changing quickly.
Violence.
Some key things to
know about violence.
Men commit the vast
majority of violence,
both what's socially
approved and what's not.
And that's about
maintaining social order.
It's about defending
the community.
There's some evidence that
maybe the classic Vikings
were an exception to that,
that women fought equally.
But in the modern
world, there don't
seem to be any exceptions,
and very few historically.
Men are also much more
likely to die violently.
In 2008, they were about three
times as likely as women.
And that's common,
that men worldwide--
this is worldwide
statistics, obviously--
are roughly, give or take
year by year, three times
as likely as women
to die violently.
But violence against
girls and women
lie behind many of those
other forms of inequality.
That's how you enforce
family discipline.
That's how you exclude
women from the workplace
and from the street.
That's how a lot of
these things happen.
Key point.
Violence is not inevitable.
It's not just oh, men
are going to be violent.
This is back to the
sex/gender thing.
Because levels of
violence vary enormously
between different societies,
and within one society
they can change quite quickly.
They can also change
over the generations.
Those Vikings, those
warlike notorious Vikings,
are the ancestors of the
modern peaceable Scandinavians.
It's the same gene pool.
So it's not about the genes.
And then as of
2011, violence had
decreased, whether one
looks at decades, centuries,
or millennia.
And here, I highly
recommend Steven
Pinker's "Better
Angels of Our Nature:
Why Violence has Declined".
The book draws a lot of that.
I can do only a little bit
with it, but it's a great book.
And he documented
this and then talked
about a variety of
reasons why that's true.
What's going on in
Syria has caused
an increase in violent
deaths, but it's too soon just
tell whether that's
sort of a blip
in the grand historical
chart or whether it
means some sort of trend.
So this is not as true over
the decades now as it was,
but we may be going back.
I hope so.
So this is drawing again
from Steven Pinker's work.
When government is not
trusted to provide security
and justice, people
have what he calls and I
call self-help justice,
where-- in my society,
if somebody robs my
house, I call the police.
I say help, somebody
robbed my house,
and they hopefully
find who did it
and, you know, they
take care of it.
Whereas in a traditional
society, if somebody steals
something from you, there's
no police to call on,
right, there's no
government to call on.
So you have to be willing
to exact retribution.
More to the point, you
need to have a reputation
to exact retribution
so that they
won't steal from you
in the first place,
and they won't beat you
up in the first place,
and they won't kill
you in the first place.
So it's a family-level thing.
And that's called honor,
that having that reputation
for being quick to
respond to insult
is essential for preservation
of groups in societies
where there is no government
that can provide protection
to families.
So you get this
culture of male honor
which gets intertwined
with this idea
of female purity, the
patrilineal society family, all
of that.
In such societies, girls
have little schooling,
women are economically
dependent on their men,
on their families, there's
high levels of violence
within the families as well as
between families, high death
rates, high birth rates--
those need to go together--
high levels of poverty, high
risk of political violence
and war, all of which reinforces
ineffective government.
There's a spiral going on here.
When girls get
educated, things change.
This seems to be
one of those levers.
So women are able to
contribute more economically
if they're more educated.
Families become more
economically stable,
because there's more people
able to do more diverse things.
Child mortality
decreases really quickly.
Giving women-- giving
girls a primary education
really affects the survival
rates of their children.
Birth rates decrease,
because families are like oh,
hopefully my kids will survive
so I can have fewer of them.
And women have more choice
in whether to have children.
So the next generation is
better educated, it's healthier,
it lives longer, and the
population size stabilizes.
Women have more say in their
families and communities.
And one of the things they
do is use those families
and communities to create
structures that help
them keep their kids alive.
It seems to be one of
those universal things.
If you give women
political power,
one of the first things they
go for is clean water supplies.
And governments provide
more public services.
It's a little more
complicated what
women do in countries like
ours, in the United States,
but in countries where
you're just on the edge,
women really like clean water.
So poverty goes down,
public health improves,
violence decreases,
chances of war decreases.
Another spiral, but going
a different direction.
So here's how to
encourage girls'
schooling in poor countries.
And there's a lot of
different parts of this.
You need schools, but you also
need the teachers and books
and internet access.
Quality is really important.
There's a lot of places
in this world where people
can go to school
for several years
and still not really become
literate or numerate.
And when parents see that their
girls are not getting educated,
they're much more likely to
take the girls out of school
because girls' labors is always
needed at home, always needed
in families.
And if the girl isn't
benefiting from the schooling,
girls are more likely
to be withdrawn.
Of course, it's
good for boys, too,
that they actually learn
something in school.
Make girls safe on the
streets and in school.
The violence thing.
Provide safe bathrooms
and sanitary supplies.
There are parts of the
world, like Pakistan,
a third of the schools have no
bathrooms and no running water.
And when girls go
off into the fields
or whatever to relieve
themselves privately,
they are more likely
to get assaulted.
This is particularly a problem
once girls start menstruating.
There are places where
pilot studies have just
given out menstrual pads, and
girls' attendance-- adolescent
girls are much more likely
to go to high school
if they have something
they can be private with.
Conditional cash transfers.
These are huge in-- particularly
Brazil and Mexico are
best-known, but there's lots of
countries around the world that
are giving cash transfers
to mothers-- much
more than fathers, because they
use the money differently--
but to poor families if
they meet certain criteria.
And typically, that includes
sending their kids to school
and getting basic medical
care, including immunizations.
And that really increases both
education and the well-being
of the next generation.
But unconditional cash
transfers can work, too.
There's been pilot
studies done in-- I
think it's Morocco and Malawi
where you just give families
a little bit of
cash, not very much,
and they're much more likely to
send their daughters to school
because they're pulled away
from that edge of survival.
And many families want their
daughters to go to school,
they just can't afford it.
Reproductive health care, again,
mothers being in good shape
means their daughters are
more likely to go to school.
And focus on
disadvantaged groups.
Nowadays, if you look
at primary education
and you look at
the dominant group,
I think it's every
country or nearly
every country,
maybe every country,
there's gender parity
at the primary level.
The place that we really
hurt around gender parity
on the primary level is
in marginalized groups
within countries.
Usually ethnic groups,
could also be a caste.
That's where you see gender
inequality within the country
at the primary level.
It gets more
complicated after that.
So those are key things
to keep in mind when
we're were talking globally.
Focusing on the
United States, there's
two things I want you to know.
Gender inequality decreased
by many different ways
between 1970 and 2000.
And since then, it
has leveled out.
We see this map over
and over and over again.
And then, educational levels.
How much education people
have, which sociologists
use as a proxy for social
class, has a much larger impact
on life patterns now than
it did in 1970 or before.
Or 1980 or before.
So here's one of my
graphs that shows this.
So this red line
is the frequency
of rape in victim studies, where
researchers get on the phone
and they call
households randomly
selected around the
country and they say,
what crime have you experienced
in the last six months.
And they tabulate this.
And so if that-- that beginning
spot is 1973 normalized to 100.
And as you see, the
incidence of rape
has gone down by roughly
3/4, 80%, since 1973.
Big change.
But it has more or less
leveled out since 2000.
The dotted line up there
is the incidence of rape
as reported to police.
Most rapes are not reported.
But the police reports went up
and up and up during this time
period when the rate
was actually going down
because of the work
to destigmatize rape
that women became more
likely to report it.
Men too, but mostly women.
And then since around
1995, the reports
have gone down at roughly
the same incidence as what's
being done by victim studies.
And then this blue
line is the murder rate
during this time period.
Again, by the same
normalization.
And as you see, the murder rate
has gone down by roughly 50%.
Violence in general
has gone down.
Lots of discussion, nobody's
really-- no consensus
about why that's true.
But the difference between
that and that, I would argue,
is gender, that there's an
increasing understanding
that gender equality is
good, that women should
be able to say no,
that coercion is not
a desirable part of masculinity.
These are all changes that
are happening with gender,
and that's making
that difference, which
is a significant difference.
Another graph.
This is the divorce rate per
1,000 people starting in 1870.
This spike is right
after World War II.
Lots of people married
in haste and came apart.
This spike is often called
the feminist movement,
but I would say it's more
broadly all the changes
of the 1960s, which were huge.
And couples didn't always
change at the same pace,
and became much more
likely to come apart.
But as you see, the divorce
rate has been coming down pretty
steeply since then.
It's still high,
historically speaking,
but that's a trend line down.
But if you look more closely
at different economic groups,
it's all among
college graduates.
So these three
lines are for people
who are not college graduates,
and they started in the '70s,
and this is when they got
married, and their chance
of divorcing within 10 years.
So those who got
married in the '70s
had a significantly
higher chance of divorce
if they were not
college graduates.
But the difference is much
more now than it was then.
And that is the
pattern that comes up
in one cluster of
statistics after another.
Here, this is life expectancies
among Americans since 1900.
And as the-- the blue
lines are for black folk
and the white lines
are for white folk.
And the solid lines
are for women,
and the dotted
lines are for men.
That will be true in all
graphs of this source.
And as you can
see, in 1900, race
was the really big
determining thing.
We had this small gender gap
which indicates high gender
inequality, and race really
affected life expectancy.
As the century has gone on,
that's somewhat reversed.
Over here, race still has an
impact, gender has an impact.
The gender gap for blacks
is significantly higher
than the gender gap for whites.
But gender and race are more
co-equal than they were.
If we look more narrowly
now to education,
it's really different.
This is for Americans with
no high school diploma
just since 1990 to 2008.
And this is the
line for white men,
and that's the line
for white women.
And as you can see,
life expectancies
for white Americans without
a high school diploma
have been going down.
They're now basically the
same as life expectancies
for black Americans without
a high school diploma.
And there's a lot of things
that are correlated with that.
Since I sent in
these slides, there
was a "New York
Times" article talking
about a recent study talking
about levels of suicide
and deaths related to substance
addiction, both alcohol
and illegal drugs.
There's a lot of despair going
on among less educated people,
and that's related
to all of this.
So the gap for
education is huge.
White men with a college
degree live 13 years longer
than white men without
a high school diploma.
For white women, the gap
is only 10 and 1/2 years,
but that's a decade.
Here-- this is one of those
things we could look at a lot,
but we won't-- this is
looking at full-time earnings,
median weekly earnings, by
gender and education since
1980.
Men's earnings average
decreased unless they
had a bachelor's degree.
These men up there with
a bachelor's degree
went up by 1/4 in terms
of their average earnings.
Women's earnings increased,
unless they did not
have a high school diploma.
So the general
trajectory for women
and the general trajectory
for men is really different.
Here, men could
pretty much count
on earning more than women
in their social world.
Now, not as much--
likely, but not as much.
Labor force participation
rates have really changed.
Men have been going
down since the 1950s.
Women obviously went up.
But then women have
also been teetering down
since around 2000.
Some of the reasons for men's
decreasing participation rate
are really good.
Men are staying
in school longer.
They're taking time off to
take care of kids or travel.
They are retiring.
In the 1950s, the typical man
died before the retirement age.
Now, the typical man
lives past retirement age.
Big difference.
Affects the labor force
participation rate.
This is good.
And they're often in
reasonably good health
if they are well-educated.
Less educated men,
however, suffer
from very high levels of
unemployment, underemployment,
and incarceration.
And they often retire
or leave the workforce
because they are in
ill health rather than
because they're ready to
move on to something else.
So it's a very
different demographic.
Here's another.
If you look at percent of
births to unmarried women, which
is getting a lot of conversation
these years, if you look
at groups of women who
did not go to college
or had some college, there
are real racial differences.
But if you look at women
with a college degree,
those racial
differences disappear.
At this point, black
and Hispanic women
have basically the same
birthrate, whether or not
they are married.
For white women,
there's a difference.
But again, among
college graduates,
the differences disappear.
Here's looking at those who
have never married by age 40.
And as you can see, there's
huge differences based
on race, gender, and education.
For black men without
a high school diploma,
it's well less than half
will ever marry by age 40,
which probably means ever.
2/3 of Americans
say that a man has
to be able to support a
family before he gets married.
1/3 of Americans think
the same for women.
So that's part of what drives
this gender difference.
Obviously lots more that
could be said there.
But this is a graph of the
ages of people when they marry.
And as you can see, back at
the turn of the 20th century,
it was really that gender
affected this a lot.
And now race affects it more.
There's been a shift
in what drives this,
what fundamentally drives this.
And this is, again,
related to these ideas
about financial stability, that
nowadays most people feel--
and this is all ages,
all genders, all race
and economic groups,
educational groups--
feel that they need to get some
sense of financial stability
before they get married.
They need to get themselves
established professionally
is what the college
graduates call it,
just some financial
stability for folks who don't
have a professional aspiration.
And in communities
where many men never
achieve financial stability,
they don't get married.
But most people want to
have children in their 20s
when it really works
well to have children.
And women in their
20s are often saying,
I can handle raising a kid
or two-- and most of them
have a kid or two,
not lots-- but I
can't take on being financially
responsible for a man as well.
So we have huge
patterns going on here.
So that gives you
a flavor what I
mean when I say that
education is really affecting
our country more than it was.
Where is gender inequality
head is my final question.
There are sort of different
possible answers to this,
and I don't-- I'm not
coming down on any one side.
But one theory is
that gender equality
will continue to increase
in the United States.
So we have a lot of
positive feedback loops
that are just going
to keep going.
Knowledge-based economy.
2/3 of women and
nearly half of men
say they believe in the
social, economic, and political
equality of the sexes.
Roughly half of those
people describe themselves
as feminists, the
other half don't.
But you know, they still believe
in equality of the genders,
so, you know.
Laws-- not always
followed, but laws
prohibit gender discrimination
and they enforce, say
that women have a right
to refuse sex and use
contraception, at least so far.
And social tolerance
of violence,
particularly sexual violence,
is decreasing, has decreased,
and seems to be
continuing to decrease.
So all of those factors
suggest that gender equality
will continue to increase.
Globally, nearly all big
international institutions,
governments-- not
all governments,
but many governments--
have realized
that increasing gender equality
and women's empowerment
seems to be key to
creating stable societies
with prosperity, with economic
stability, good economies, lack
of violence.
All of this seems
to be intertwined.
I'm not saying anything
radically new here.
World Bank will say it, too.
And many poor and
middle income countries
have started a positive cycle
of more education, more women's
employment, increasing
health, women's empowerment.
These are things-- again,
positive feedback cycles
going in a good direction.
There are theories, however,
that gender equality
will stagnate.
As I said, in the US
metrics have stagnated since
around 2000.
Women still have
primary responsibility
for unpaid family
work everywhere, even
in the most egalitarian
countries, like Sweden,
the Nordic countries.
They're working on it,
but it's still really
women's ultimate responsibility
for their families.
And for less lucky and
prosperous countries,
ethnic groups that are
marginalized or stigmatized,
or live in war zones, often
have really high levels
of gender inequality, along
with all the other things
they are suffering.
And it's really hard
to break those cycles
for stigmatized or
violence-prone areas.
So, theories that gender
inequality will increase.
Societies tend to become more
stagnant and more intolerant
and more full of resentment
when an economic situation is
either level or falling.
When people have a falling
standard of living,
they often feel that they
need to find someone to blame.
And this can intersect
with masculinity,
that if a man feels like
it's his responsibility
to be a breadwinner
and to be, therefore,
in control of his
family, and he can't
do that, men can
become very resentful.
And some men try to shore up
their sense of masculinity
by exercising it in
other ways, i.e.,
dominating women and
dominating children.
So that is a pattern
that has been seen
in many different contexts.
If the United States
is headed into a period
of economic decline, or some
people in the United States
are headed into a long
period of economic decline,
this pattern has its obvious
risks-- and other countries
as well, not just
the United States.
And then, women tend
to suffer more than men
from political and
economic instability
from social disorder and war.
Children suffer the most,
right, because they're
the most vulnerable.
But the more a woman has to work
to keep her family alive just
subsisting, the lesser
she has for anything else.
And climate change and
environmental stresses,
economic stresses, look
like they are increasing.
The Pentagon has
put out research
suggesting that there's
going to be increasing
economic instability,
political instability,
and military
instability worldwide.
So they're preparing for that.
Again, I don't know if that's
what's going to happen,
but it certainly
is a possibility
that environmental stresses will
lead to more social stresses,
will lead to more gender
inequality in countries
where those cycles
can actually reverse.
So thank you very
much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
Comments?
AUDIENCE: So the part where
women are graduating college
now more than men, how does
that track by class and race?
LORI KENSCHAFT: It's
more true for families
where the parents did
not go to college.
So in elite families, it's very
likely that all of the children
will go to college
no matter what.
Small exceptions not.
But families where some people
go to college and some people
not, that's where you
really see the differences,
that girls are
more likely to go.
And one of the reasons
for that, it is believed,
is gender discrimination
in the workforce.
That, at any given level of
education, the boy or young man
is more likely to get a
job and a better paid job
than the woman at that level.
So women have to get
more education in order
to get economic equality.
And then on top of that,
women see themselves
as having primary
responsibility for children.
So they really want to
get economic stability.
So there's gender issues
driving the motivations
in families that are less
elite, less privileged.
AUDIENCE: When you
talked about factors
that affect a family's decision
about whether to support
their daughters going to
school, you mostly talked
about factors that were
internal to the family,
the economic situation
or the attitudes
towards the girls' education.
One of the things that's been
surprising watching the world
news, at least for me
over the last decade,
is the growth of the
belief of a political,
cultural-- that I have the
right to tell other families not
to send their
daughters to school,
that that's seen as a major
political plank of a group
like Boko Haram or in Pakistan.
And I was curious
whether you see that
as being the outgrowth
of economic factors,
or is this something that also
could play into, unfortunately,
one of those last three slides?
LORI KENSCHAFT: Absolutely.
The real answer is
very complicated,
as you can imagine.
And I glossed over it.
But that safety
issue, that a lot
of how the Taliban, Boko
Haram, other extremist groups
have deterred parents from
sending their kids to school,
particularly their daughters,
is by making schools
seem threatening, that
there may be violence there.
There isn't violence
all the time, obviously.
But if you're scared
that your kid is
going to get attacked, raped,
killed for going to school,
you're less likely to
send them to school.
And you know, Boko
Haram literally
means Western knowledge or
Western education is forbidden,
or is taboo.
And I see those movements
as very much part
of a reaction against Western
ideology, Western colonization.
And I'm not justifying it
there, but saying, yes,
there is a global debate
that's going on now.
And one of the places it's
playing out is on this dispute
on who should have control
over people's bodies,
particularly girls'
and women's bodies.
Should it be the
family and community,
as it was in
traditional societies,
or should it be the individual?
Most of the world sees the
United States and Europe
as saying individuals should
have control over their bodies,
over their destinies, over how
they dress, how they behave.
And the men of Boko
Haram and the Taliban
see that as a real
threat to them as men,
but also to their whole
traditional society
that's based on
the group defining
what individuals will do.
So gender is one of the places
that this fundamental argument
over where the locus of control
should be is playing out.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So how do you imagine
the impact of the birth gender,
sex inequality in 15, 20
years in China, in India,
or in Africa?
Now that those kids are
maturing into adults,
but the gender
equality is all off.
LORI KENSCHAFT:
Thank you for asking.
It's not just in the future.
It's happening now,
because this has
been going on as long as people
have had access to ultrasounds.
And that's young adults now.
And so particularly in
China, India, Vietnam,
a few other places, you
have really big disparities.
And there's real concerns
about the militarization that
happens when a society has
too many men, that they
need young men.
Young men who can't
settle into a family
are often pretty hard to
control, and particularly
in societies where the
sense of membership,
the sense of belonging, is
still very strongly rooted
in families.
China, as I said, is
changing very quickly.
And that's partly because
of the ideological changes.
It's partly because of
the economic changes
driven by industrialization.
But it isn't like a society
changes instantaneously
overnight.
And so young men
in China now know
that they have really hard
odds around getting married.
The elite ones are going to,
but the less elite ones are not.
Same thing in India,
where one of the things
we talk about in the
book is issues of rape.
And we focus on India
and the United States.
But there are a lot
of young men in India,
lower status young men, who
know that they're never going
to be able to afford to marry.
And in a society where marriage
is how you get your value out
of life, that can
be devastating.
So yes, this is already rippling
through these societies.
The key thing that I'm going
to take the opportunity to add
is that South Korea
used to be in this camp,
and among adults, it still is.
But if you go back
and look at the graph,
now there's some sex-selective
abortion going on
in South Korea, but
not nearly as much,
not enough to show
up on the map.
And the reason for
that, it seems,
is partly ideological--
preaching about gender equality
and all of that-- but
even more, the country
put in a strong public pension
service for older adults.
Because in traditional
societies, when you get old,
you need to rely on your
children to keep you alive.
And in traditional
societies where only males
can have access to good jobs
and ownership of property,
that means you
need to have sons,
or you're going to be destitute.
And South Korea got access to
ultrasounds and good, simple
abortion technology at a stage
where parents still depended
on their sons to survive.
Industrialized
societies, people tend
to want to have one, two,
maybe three children.
Sometimes zero.
And so they were using
sex-selective abortion
to make sure they'd be
secure in their old age.
Once the country started
putting in equivalent to social
security, the use of
sex-selective abortion
went down a lot.
That works.
Making it illegal doesn't work.
It's illegal in China.
It's illegal in India.
It's happening.
So that's the key thing there.
And yes, those societies
are consciously
and intentionally struggling
with these problems.
AUDIENCE: And do
you think that would
lead to more gender
inequality, or to greater
valuation of women?
LORI KENSCHAFT: It can lead to
a greater valuation of women
as sexual and reproductive
partners, which
tends to lead to more gender
inequality in the broader
political and economic realm.
China has had an
increase in what's
called wife theft, or wife
capture, where you grab a woman
and go marry her whether or
not she was already married.
That's an extreme form
of gender inequality--
whether or not she
consents, obviously,
if it's by physical capture.
And that's not
happening everywhere,
but that is one of
the patterns that's
emblematic of what happens
when there's a real gender
imbalance, that women get valued
as sexual and reproductive
objects.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank
you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]